je suis avec patrick de père glace
depuis paris vous avez été reçu par le
premier ministre expliquez-nous ce
chemin on peut dire ça parcouru depuis
votre départ de chalon sur saône
tout à fait j'ai parcouru plus de 350 km
à pied en faisant la grève de la faim de
chalon sur saône
j'ai commencé par mettre mon camion au
milieu d'un rond point face à l'hôtel
des impôts à chalon sur saône et je
savais que j'allais avoir du mal à être
entendre j'avais pourtant pris deux
fauteuils pour avoir un dialogue avec le
maire avec le sous-préfet avec le préfet
mais personne n'est venu
donc vous pouvez jouer était conséquente
et j'ai aidé j'ai décidé de partir pour
paris à pied rencontré le président de
la république il faut vraiment que je
m'assoie je suis vraiment désolé on va
on va on va continuer donc que vous
vouliez voir le président et c'est
finalement premier ministre qui vous a
reçu j'ai été bloqué deux fois au palais
de l'elysée par la police j'ai été à
l'assemblée nationale où j'étais bloqué
je ne pouvais même pas faire 20 mètres
pour prendre une photo et j'avais
toujours espoir j'ai failli abandonner
mais mon ami david qui a créé la page
facebook 30 jours pour le peuple était
là pour m'aider pour m'épauler pour me
donner m'aider dans mes dialogues dans
mes propos pour que je sois toujours
serein et toujours sur l'idée que
j'avais et ça a payé j'ai reçu un appel
et on m'a demandé mon numéro
d'immatriculation et je suis rentré à
matignon et j'ai rencontré pendant 40
minutes le premier ministre votre
message a été entendu quelle a été la
teneur du dialogue en deux mots en deux
mots le premier ministre était un être
humain comme moi un homme comme moi nous
sommes assis là en face de l'autre dans
un salon nous avons discuté en ouvrant
tous les deux notre coeur et mon message
est entré dans son coeur il le fera
passer au président de la république un
message pour vos amis gilet jaune dans
votre région ils doivent continuer le
mouvement
le mouvement doit continuer tant que
nous n'avons pas quelque chose de
concret mais en tout cas sans violence
sans bloquer les gens dans les ronds
points
moi je suis un pacifiste et je fais tout
ça pour éviter une deuxième révolution
qui aurait fait des milliers de morts
j'ai mis ma voix ma vie en péril
et j'étais prêt à aller jusqu'au bout à
partir de duplus de la cour de matignon
j'ai retrouvé mon véhicule j'ai repris
du sucre et je vais me ré alimentés avec
du yaourt et je vais écouter ce que le
médecin peut me dire et pour moi je vais
pouvoir retourner voir ma femme mes
enfants mes amis et mes proches et
redisparaître et redevenir invisible
merci à votre message en tout cas est
passé auprès de toute la france et
spécialement aussi dans votre région